brace yourselves the Cable Guy is coming
ever since the post-credits tees at the
end of the smash hit Deadpool comic-book
fans have been excitedly awaiting the
arrival of cable oh but I can't tell you
one thing and it's a bit of a secret the
sequel we're gonna have cable and ever
since that post-credits t's non
comic-book fans have been wondering who
the heck is cable well we're about to
answer that question for you because
here's a dangerously in-depth look at
everything Marvel fans need to know
about Marvel's most complicated mutants
[Music]
a convoluted history
if you thought x-men Days of Future past
was confusing grab a bottle of aspirin
and lie down because cables convoluted
history makes that film look like
child's play which is fitting because
cable began messing up x-men continuity
from the moment he was born
see cable is actually Nathan summers the
son of Scott Summers aka Cyclops and a
lady named Madeleine fryer who is
actually an evil clone of Jean Grey
Cyclops and the real Jean Grey then
raised Nathan for all of a hot minute
before apocalypse infected the baby with
the tech enviros a disease that turns
flesh into parasitic robotic circuitry
in order to save him
Cyclops and Jean gave him to a
time-traveling prophet from the distant
future named mother s Connie who was
actually their daughter from an
alternate universe it was tragic but
then Scott and Jean sent their
consciousness into the future as well
inhabiting host bodies in order to
secretly raise their son in the future
without his knowledge
so yay after he became an adult
Capel spent decades time traveling
around history battling the forces of
apocalypse as a grizzled old man he
finally returned at the time period of
his birth and became leader of the new
mutants turning them into a paramilitary
mutant team called x-force eventually he
revealed his purpose was to protect a
messiah baby who was supposed to save
mutant kind he adopted her naming her
hope and then did a bunch of
time-traveling things to protect her
from other folks who wanted to get her
this is important because clues of the
Deadpool 2 trailer like cables teddy
bear suggest that protecting hope may be
a major part of the plot for the film
got all that good because things are
about to get even more confusing clones
and doppelgangers considering his mother
was an evil clone of Jean Grey it's only
fitting that cable himself also has an
evil clone named strife cables clone was
kidnapped at a young age by apocalypse
and raised to become the vessel for
apocalypsis consciousness when his
current host body died that didn't work
out however so strife got to just be an
evil cable instead but with a really
cool giant helmet not quite so cool is
Nate gray the x-man an alternate
universe version of cable whose mom was
actually
Weil Jean Grae this Nate never got the
metal arm and stuff but he did get a
[ __ ] in 90s haircut a jacket so we'll
call that beep honestly you know what we
can't even figure out this crap anymore
just pretend to make sense and let's
move on
convoluted powers if you're wondering
just what cables actual powers are
you're not alone as they're almost as
confusing as his backstory thanks to his
mom he inherited extremely powerful
telekinetic and telepathic abilities
however he often can't use either
because those powers are entirely spent
keeping the techno virus from turning
him into a full-on robot don't worry
though because he has other powers at
least sometimes while he usually uses a
time machine to travel through the ages
sometimes he can just do it himself and
other times he can predict the future as
well his robot arm also gives him super
string and he has a ton of super
advanced guns from the future which he
loves shooting people with and sometimes
one of his eyes glows for no apparent
reason which is a fantastic party trick
straight man cable is a grim and gritty
avatar of deadly serious earnestness
which makes him a perfect foil for
Deadpool who is you know exactly the
opposite in every way the one thing they
do have in common though is they both
love guns
not to mention superfluous pouches on
their costumes as a straight man for
Deadpool to play off of cable has no
equal the survival of Earth entirely
depends on the long road to the big
screen after cable was teased at the end
of Deadpool the big question for fans
was who is going to play him finding the
answer turned out to be quite a sucker
while fans rally behind avatars Stephen
Lang rumors claimed that Deadpool
director Tim Miller zijn systems on
casting Kyle Chandler in the role led to
his ultimate departure from the
franchise Miller denied this but the
production reportedly considered
everyone from Brad Pitt to david Harbor
in the role before finally landing on
Josh Brolin and Brolin is pumped for the
role both literally and figuratively
there's a lot of stuff going on a
Deadpool that's very surprising and that
will be very satisfying when you see it
it to me it's even funnier than the
first one we can't wait thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]